hello and welcome to trigonometry hi
guys welcome again we just wanted to
give you a quick update on what's going
on with us first of all in the last
couple of weeks we've again had some
people give us some one-off donations
which have been very helpful and as
always we want to say a huge thank you
to all of you who subscribe to us on
subscribe' star that would give us money
through PayPal and who are patrons on
patreon and this really helps because as
you will probably know if you follow our
social media pretty much every single
video that we put out is actually
demonetised in advance now so we know
we're not gonna get any money before
we've even put them out so if you're
already someone who gives us money
please continue to do that and if you're
someone who enjoys the show who believes
in what we're doing this is your chance
to help us make the show and continue to
make it as great as it is and also as
well if you're one of those people who
thinks do you know what I can't give
money but I can offer a particular
service that you think can make the show
better we would really love that as well
in particular personal dresser for
Constantine let's get him some work done
let's get that hair trimmed I think it'd
be look good Mike I love the way you've
made that joke when you're the one that
gets all the comments about your
appearance my jealous and rightfully so
but if you if you think oh you know for
example that you could help us maybe I
mean we've already got someone who's
very very kindly offered to help us with
a website but if there's anything else
please get in contact and we'd be ever
so grateful now just give us money I'm
Jewish give us money and on and on that
note guys thank you very much and we'll
see you again soon